you and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
hi I'm Rosanna Lockwood here on
uncensored tonight Donald Trump's
Twitter account used to be the stuff of
Comedy gold but now he's under criminal
investigation and it's all turned very
serious indeed could what's lurking in
the former president's private DMS
prevent him standing for office again
was a teenager when she made the
decision to undergo gender reassignment
surgery now she is suing her former
doctors claiming they coerced her into a
double mastectomy I'll be talking to her
live
and nothing on the Telly over the summer
apart from here I'll talk to you of
course then why not try the latest
viewing sensation skip TV we have the
bald Builders behind it all to explain
it
[Music]
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood well this time a week
ago I was sat in this very seat four
Piers hosting a two-hour special as we
watched Donald Trump get indicted for
the third time he's amassed so many
criminal charges now facing so many
trials and yes he remains intensely
popular latest polls putting him
actually way out in front of the
Republican nominee for the next run at
the White House Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis the only other Contender really
breaking into those double digits but
still actually trailing far behind Trump
now today I've been mulling this with
the uncensored team including some of
our American colleagues as well why is
Trump so popular not only Among Us
voters but internationally too now some
argue it's his Mastery of manipulation
and deceit others say it is no-nonsense
policies that speak to real people but
there is one common thread that unites
even the left and the right Trump is
funny
[Music]
Don't Call Him a fat pig
they would love to see a guy like sleepy
Joe Biden who has no clue what the hell
he's doing
because my hair I don't know about you
but it has to be perfect
I wonder who did that to our minds
I don't believe it was Joe you know who
it was
crooked Hillary myself
[Music]
bro whether you are laughing with him as
he slams crooked Hillary or laughing at
him as he
dad dances out of an Escalade Trump is
not afraid to be laughing stock and that
is because he knows the true currency of
humor attention attention means more air
time means more influencing it means
more fans followers and popularity that
doesn't mean he's a good politician but
it probably means he is a successful one
now one place he of course used to do
all this was Twitter before he was
banned no politician or leader has ever
used social media like Trump did now or
does on his true social platform now now
we know that the lawyer investigating
Trump in this latest indictment actually
obtained a search warrant for Trump's
Twitter account now presumably there are
probably a lot less gags in the DMS
we're finding out more about that
shortly but ask more journalists and
they will say despite the turbulence of
Trump's presidency and the real world
impacts of his words and actions it was
an interesting time when he was in power
and the same consultant be said for
other candidates I mean have you seen
Biden's attempt to have a sense of humor
Grand Canyon one of the Earth's nine
wonders Wonders of the World happy
birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
well Mr President Mr President I just
come out of you
now of course when I'll say you know I
back Trump over by and you know me by
now in the types of politics I'm into uh
but we're talking here about humor and
why it works for one side or another and
it's a particular weak spot for
Democrats and indeed liberals and left
wing as the world over why do
left-leaning candidates so often lose
against conservatives in debates You
could argue it's because they're so
focused on the importance of their
arguments that they often lose the
ability to relate to people to be human
and like it or not it's an honest
reality people vote for candidates that
they like and having a sense of humor is
a shortcut to popularity unfortunately
it's also really hard to fake so short
of another Obama if the Democrats really
want to stop a court jester getting back
into the White House they'd probably
better find one of their own well to
discuss this more and join here in the
studio by Static comedian and podcaster
Eric McElroy and News Review editor at
the Sunday Times Josh glancy thanks to
both of you we also joined in the US by
a Donald Trump's former lawyer
also joining us down the line
billionaire businessman and investor
Kevin O'Leary all four of you thank you
we've got a lot to get through I will
start with the comedian that joins us
here on the panel of the studio uh you
were watching that Eric
um
are we wildly out of touch here or is
Trump a funny person no you could when
you watch him do a speech when he either
when he's doing a joke or even when he's
trying out ideas he plays the room like
he's a stand-up comedian like when we do
comedy we can't just make things funny
out of thin air we have to try in front
of people you feel it and you change it
and you adjust it and you can see the
way he plays with the crowd plays to the
things that they like him to say and
then you know and then Builds on that
even in his political ideas he tries
them out like we would try out a joke in
a way I saw somebody mention the fact
that he almost sometimes can leave off
the final word of a sentence and he'll
mime it instead and that leaves him open
to lack of prosecution on one thing but
it's also just a sort of tactics do you
think he's really thinking about his
angles like a comedian does I mean he
def he definitely has a natural Charisma
I mean he's not somebody that I've ever
supported but I think you're right about
the likability thing and if you go back
since it's we've had televised debates
in America we the likable candidates
whether you like their politics or not
has always won and Trump was more
likable than Hillary and I say that for
somebody who fully endorsed Hillary in
all of her policies and wanted her to
win but she was not that Charming person
that you wanted to hang out with and and
listen to for a while so do you think my
point about uh Democrats not really
having a sense of humor is uh unfair
well no I mean Obama is a great example
if you see his um his uh of the speeches
that he made for the Press Association
dinners um the Washington Prescott those
were very very funny and he has great
comic timing but you're right Biden
feels more like he would tell you dad
jokes Trump's going to pull you in and
tell you the dirty little naughty joke
let's go to Kevin O'Leary and ask him a
bit more about that the naughty dirty
little jokes that Trump asks are they
part of his brand Kevin
I think people have got to know him
quite well the straightforwardness the
transparency sometimes outrageous
statements other people have got
canceled for saying the same things and
somehow he's the Teflon man but what's
remarkable over the last six weeks as
these indictments started pouring on
were past 70 indictments 7-0 indictments
many of them should he be found guilty
would get him 20 years in a federal
prison
um he's not talking about that they keep
coming we have another set of maybe as
many as a hundred more coming out of
Atlanta uh for trying attempting to
change the vote in Georgia
and now the entire population seems to
be getting numb to this piling on of
indictments in fact both sides are under
scrutiny now this seems to be a new kind
of political Warfare where each side
tries to indice the other person or
their family in the case of Biden's son
Hunter Biden it looks like by the time
we get debates between the presidential
candidates they'll both be wearing ankle
bracelets and that's new in America but
people don't seem to care Trump is on a
different mandate now he's he's cracking
jokes as you've just detailed he's not
talking about indictments or prison time
he's not attacking Biden personally he's
attacking his policies we are five
months early this usually doesn't start
till the November before the election
here we are in August in America and we
are getting very detailed policies out
of trump attacking foreign policy on
Biden attacking economic domestic policy
energy policy very specific claims and
that's unique and it's actually getting
quite a bit of traction and why we're
doing and we're seeing this they both
have 43 percent so in other words you
can't elect either of these people
without the the people who haven't
decided the undecided voters and Trump
is going after them now with policy
fascinating Let's cross over to Alan
dershowitz who of course uh has
performed as a lawyer for Trump before
he's a close friend of the show he's was
on us for the on with us for the
indictment last week as well Alan can
you talk us and our audience through
some of the latest things that are
happening in this Myriad of legal cases
against Trump uh we've had new
information this evening uh just about
the Mar-A-Lago files which of course I
think was the second indictment if I'm
not losing count
yeah well first of all Trump is an
invention of the media particularly the
media who oppose them CNN gave him the
presidency in
2016. and he manages to turn the tax on
him into humor sometimes intended
sometimes it's not when I finished
arguing for him on behalf of the Senate
um and I think I did a good job and he
called me the next day I expected him to
say thank you he said Alan I hope you
will thank me for making you famous now
I don't think he even thought that was
funny but to me
finally I I occasionally see him say
things that are dead serious but they
seem funny people look at it as being
funny and I think the fact that he's
being attacked so much and in my case in
my opinion often unfairly of the three
indictments so far against them two of
them are absolutely unfair the only
possibly Fair one is the one in Florida
where he was waving classified material
in front of unauthorized people but I
think Americans don't like bullies even
if there are bullies going after bullies
I think that it's turned a lot of people
in Trump's Direction who don't like him
but they want to object to how he's
being persecuted by the other side and
by prosecutors and by some in the media
so he's managed to figure out a way by
using humor of turning the attacks on
him against his enemies and in his favor
it's it's a rare Talent I've never ever
seen it before in any politician neither
Obama nor Clinton who had a good sense
of humor were able to do that he has
this remarkable ability to turn attacks
into humorous defenses and attacks
against his attackers his nicknames for
example they're pretty dumb nicknames
they're lame but he managed it laughs
from calling people these names I
wouldn't laugh at it I guess
extraordinary traction with them crooked
Hillary Rhonda sanctimonious meatball
run he needs one after it once and he
gets into the public imagination
um Alan just while we've got you I just
want to ask you about this latest detail
on on Trump's Twitter DMS basically
um that the new the special counsel for
the new indictment got a warrant to get
access to Trump's Twitter account it was
blocked at Thursday Etc where are we in
that um how serious could that be
I don't think it would be very serious
first he's going to attack the warrant
but second of all I can't imagine what's
on his Twitter account which he hasn't
made public Donald Trump doesn't
understand
privacy or confidentiality everything he
thinks about he says publicly he is not
a private person so I doubt that his
Twitter account will have any smoking
guns or anything that he hasn't already
said in public who knows but that's my
guess yeah it does seem to be all out
there doesn't it let's come to the
studio again now and speak to Josh who
joins us
Josh you study the news as part of your
job basically and when you think about
Trump and the way he's seen
internationally as well especially from
here in the UK do you think he's going
to win again with that same routine that
we've just been analyzing
well I mean I covered the 2020 election
on the ground and it was very noticeable
for me then that a fair proportion of
Americans who maybe didn't hate Trump's
policies were just exhausted with the
guy I mean four years of trump in
America was the most dizzying draining
Preposterous experience I've ever had
and many shared that view and I think
that's really why he lost because a fair
chunk of Americans who weren't wanting
one camp or the other just thought you
know what enough this biting guy he
seems boring sleepy fine let's do that
for a bit
um so the question is this time around
is that sort of exhausted middle still
there I suspect it probably is but Trump
will out campaign Biden if it comes
between the two of them he's got more
energy than Biden he's clearly funnier
than Biden we know that
um so and Biden does have this problem
with his age and with his mental acuity
so I would say Biden probably Shades it
but it really is a coin toss as any
country as polarized as America is going
to be in a two horse race and do you
think comparisons would try his way of
using humor as a tactic and Boris
Johnson a well-founded
well they're almost archetypes of their
different countries aren't they so Boris
Johnson is the witty uh erudite etonian
who's good at sort of quoting the
classics uh inappropriate moments and
Trump is the Brash Wise Guy New Yorker
who says on a cruel funny it'll put
downs and knows how to get under
people's skin so in in some ways they
had a lot in common in some ways they
couldn't be more different Uh Kevin uh
listening into that I want to ask you
what you make a Josh's assessment there
of us Brits as well the way we perceive
Trump
um maybe it's similar to how you guys
see Boris Johnson
I always thought Boris was a
was very entertaining and and I've come
to the conclusion this is you know from
Napoleonic times great leaders are
amazing storytellers right from Attila
the Hun right through to Napoleon Trump
Boris Johnson they tell stories people
are captivated in listening to them and
as a result they feel their brand when
they're at the polling booth and I think
that's exactly how Boris Johnson did it
I was surprised when he was trying to
make his comeback they didn't get more
attraction because I never felt his uh
you know removal and of course I
understand the British parliamentary
system because I'm an Irish and a
Canadian citizen so I watch these things
happen when your own caucus decides you
can't win a majority mandate they take
you behind the barn and shoot you and
that's what happened to him but in in a
way these these remarkable politicians
in modern times the Trump story and
Boris and and even even Maggie Thatcher
was a hell of a Storyteller I used I was
mesmerized growing up listening to her
and you know studying politics and
history great storytellers are
successful politicians doesn't speak to
their policies that's different the
ability to get elected is the first
thing you have to do then you have to
execute great storytellers also a great
businessman Uh Kevin uh Eric you were
listening into that in the studio and I
want to ask you whether you think
there's any sort of Link then between
being a great Storyteller and the types
of a sort of career burnout we've seen
if we can call it that and that's kind
of Boris Johnson as a leader Trump as a
leader you know Finding themselves
facing investigations and criminal
charges yeah I think Trump's whole
schtick and that's what his his fans and
hardcore supporters really like they
like the fact that he punches down you
know picks on people they enjoy that
kind of Comedy it's a comedy of Cruelty
because it's not normally the rule in
comedies you punch up Man's power well
Trump has been the most powerful man in
the world and so he picks on people and
they seem to enjoy that and it feels
like some of it I don't know how much
that expands the base that likes him
because you're right you're probably
exhausted from it after all these years
of it and the people who seem to be
coming back to him want that last sort
of hurray of the band that maybe is a
little bit too tired and maybe should
have packed it up a few years ago oh
goodness we'll have to wait and see if
the trumpet is still playing look all
four of you thank you very much for an
interesting discussion
here on uncensored next tonight we're
going to be speaking to the woman suing
her doctors for allegedly encouraging
her to become a man should there be more
rigorous medical assessments for those
wanting gender reassignment surgery
we'll be asking that next
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now how long
should someone have to wait before
receiving gender reassignment treatment
last year lawyers argued that NHS
England had failed for me to duty to
ensure that 92 percent of patients
referred for non-urgent care start
treatment within 18 weeks the high court
actually rejected that in America
meanwhile a number of lawsuits are being
brought by people who say they were
rushed too quickly into treatment by the
medical establishment now one of them is
Soren adalke a woman from Texas who is
suing doctors who she says acted like
ideologues pushing her into gender
reassignment surgery at 18 rather than
treating her for anxiety and depression
Sauron claims surgeons opted for a risky
procedure and botched her double
mastectomy she then de-transitioned just
six months later Soren joins us now
along with her lawyer Ron Miller uh the
two of you really want to thank you for
sharing your time with us I understand
this case is very much open which is why
your lawyer joins us Ron thank you very
much for making the time as well
um sorry thanks for letting me share
your story but it's best if it comes
from you just just give the audience a
sense of what happened to you
so yeah I mean I
first started really exploring my
identity as a teenager which is totally
normal for teenagers to do it in fact uh
extremely normal part of our adolescent
development but when I was
hospitalized for a psychiatric episode
at age 15 I was coerced into uh
admitting that I was trans or telling
you know the practitioner that I was
trans by the psychiatrist seeing me and
from there I was pretty quickly
medicalized started attending a support
group where I was affirmed and found
that sense of community that I think a
lot of adolescents crave and desire and
at age 17 I started testosterone at age
19 I had my healthy breasts amputated in
a double mastectomy and six months later
before I even turned 20 years old I
ideologically detransitioned and along
with that stopped the use of hormones
and also correcting anybody on how they
perceived me wow well a journey you have
been on uh sorry and very brave of you
to now be sharing your story the world
but you're also bringing a court case I
understand in Texas against the medical
professionals who advised you who
carried out these procedures
um and you know Ron feel free to pick up
at this point if there's something you
think you should add legally here um but
why is it that you're bringing this case
to court
sorry go ahead yeah I think Soren yeah I
think Soren's perfectly capable of
answering this one she's she's very
familiar with their lawsuit
sorry what has uh LED you to bring yeah
we're bringing this case because we see
this happening uh to people besides just
me but because what happened to me was
was preventable I mean these
practitioners overlooked so many red
flags and my mental health and why I was
uh you know pursuing this treatment why
this treatment was being recommended to
me even
um in providing it to me and you know I
think that the legal route because the
medical community has failed to
regulate itself it's going to be the way
that we bring about this change and this
sort of caution when dealing when with
irreversible medical interventions
so this isn't a class action lawsuit
this isn't multiple parties this is your
lawsuit but you're hoping well not
hoping but by doing so you think that
more people might be encouraged to do
the same have you met people in your
position
yeah I mean I've met lots of people who
at least underwent similar in
interventions to me who dealt with
practitioners who you know threatened
them and their families who
um I mean just had this feeling of wrong
that I think has brought about more by
sort of cultural limitations on what men
and women can do on what they can wear
on what activities are appropriate for
them to partake in and you know I don't
think we should be addressing something
societal with this pursuit of physical
uh change you know we've that that's not
been true for for any other case in
history
um and I I don't think it's true now and
what was it about the way that the
medical practitioners approached your
case that made you think that they were
approaching it ideologically rather than
medically
well there wasn't any question of why I
thought the way I thought all of them
seemed very happy to help me along in my
struggle I I mean I had a practitioner
who whose partner was
um you know transgender I had another
practitioner whose child was transgender
and it seemed like a lot of them had
personal Stakes
um in my case and weren't really
treating my case objectively as I would
expect from somebody who is supposed to
be helping me rather than enabling me
okay and I will bring one in on this one
I just talk a little bit about preparing
for this uh case have you dealt with any
similar ones like this uh Ron and what
will the your sort of uh case be based
around what is the kind of testimony or
evidence that you're bringing
yeah we we have unfortunately dealt with
several other cases that are similar to
sorens not exactly the same but have
similar uh fact patterns so to speak
um where a medical provider is
essentially fast tracking the patient
down this course of gender affirming
treatments that include cross-ex
hormones and surgeries to their bodies
uh you know for for females it usually
starts with a double mastectomy uh for
males you've got anectomies and and
other surgeries that will permanently
disfigure their bodies and so we've seen
these cases and and we are you know
bringing other cases
um against these medical practitioners
urging a sense of caution and and care
just follow the normal standard of care
these are medical malpractice cases
there's a standard of care that you know
to do no harm uh to to make sure that
you're using the least invasive medical
intervention possible and these
practitioners seem to jump to almost the
most medically invasive
possibility right off the bat without
even ruling out the other ones and so
each of these cases share similar fact
patterns and and will be brought under
these these kind of uh causes across the
country okay really interesting look
sorry and before we let you go how do
you feel about the court case you've
been brave enough to share your account
with us here on television
um do you feel ready to talk about it in
court
I do I mean I feel like this is bigger
than me and that's a lot of what is
motivating me knowing that while I was
so into myself for so long so concerned
with my pain and you know um my life and
what direction that was going to take I
I feel like I know now that I'm part of
this Collective of humanity and while I
care for myself as part of that I know
that
um you know when I I stand before that
chord I'm going to be doing something
that's going to have lasting effects for
years for decades for centuries perhaps
Millennia to come and ensuring that um
our health our mental health especially
is taken seriously
and Ron as well your lawyer thank you
very much for sharing your story with us
this evening we appreciate it
now bringing this story back over here
to the United Kingdom of course
different systems they've got this
private healthcare system over there in
the U.S that's the medical establishment
that's being uh that's taken to court in
that case here in the United Kingdom
it's mostly NHS isn't it and in terms of
points of view in this debate often
brought up on this uh show a lot some
think trans people have to wait too long
for treatment here in the UK especially
here with the NHS and Freda Wallace is a
trans rights campaigner host of gender
nebulous podcasts joins me now to
discuss this reader not our first rodeo
you and I met a few months ago here
right right nice to speak to you again
hopefully it won't be it's so chaotic
this time it was fiery wasn't it free
day it was a little bit and I do
apologize if I was a little bit too
aggressive but I know I I'm I'm I speak
well because I care about what I say you
know and it was interesting to listen to
that story there because there was a
mention of something being ideologically
driven now transfer people are not
ideologically driven trans just happens
to be something we are now we have to
fit into society with that and sadly
because of the history of the
medicalization of our experience part of
that is going through psychological
processes going through checks and
balances with doctors gatekeeping of
medications we might need it's a very
very difficult to be trans if you were a
young person now and you were coming out
as trans you could expect to wait as
long as seven years for a first
appointment and that's just and it's
true of any NHS service at the moment
sadly the NHS is so underfunded I don't
know really why we're talking about this
as a trans issue because it's a mental
health issue as well because
unfortunately like I said before the way
the trans experience has been codified
it's become a mental health it comes
under mental health really but I
disagree with that and unfortunately
not to take away anything from that
person's experience because I don't know
them but we hear more about the
transitioners than we hear about the
trans medical experience because it's
it's that is the thing that is
politically and ideologically driven we
have to talk about trans people human
beings and and another thing that sticks
out to me about this is this idea of
medicalization we're often talked about
oh you can't just change into a woman if
you have surgeries the surgery thing
isn't really the important thing for me
it's the social things being accepted
socially accepted to be accepted in law
you know if I went to get married say if
I wanted to if I was involved in some
complex legal situation and the thing
that would change that the thing that
would Empower and make young people
happy would be self-id that is the thing
that would change all that and it would
be so easy to it's already gone through
in Scotland it would have been it would
have it would have been law now in
Scotland but Westminster blocked it and
it was blocked for ideological reasons
it wasn't blocked for any medical reason
it wasn't blood for any safeguarding
reasons it's been proved time and time
again that self ID only is it's like the
high tide that lifts all boats that's
what self ID is self and I know no idea
is that important because obviously it
is the bone of biggest contention I
think when it comes to the gender
identity debate here in the United
Kingdom
um you know the common refrain you hear
is from saying I will give you the
pronouns you want socially in public but
self ID I.E signing a legal declaration
to change your sex legally and
officially there is a lot of opposition
to that but you're saying yeah the
opposition is ideological and political
and and they've had to I mean if you
think if you look at the conversation
about it they have to think the people
that are against that have to find the
worst case scenarios in the world they
will scour the world for the one time
someday uh say some someday with a
sexual predator and happen to be trans
and they will that story will make it to
the Daily Mail and and we know that self
ID would not change it would not affect
any of that we know that because it's
all we're already self ID exists in like
I think it's 20 countries now and
there's no reports of it being a problem
and the actual U.N the U.N had to
intervene actually in the in the
Scottish debate because uh Victor uh
ball lost from the UN he had to
intervene and say this is inhumane this
goal is against human rights and that's
why baroness Faulkner is currently being
investigated for a Corruption of the
ehrc and that's where we are that's
where trans people are at the moment
Rosanna yeah and the thing that would
change it and make everybody happier we
wouldn't nested we wouldn't need to feel
validated by a medical experience if we
felt that the government and people who
make laws are actually batting for us uh
can I just add I mean I've spotted I've
written I've written so many politicians
and there are some good people out there
and Tory Park spoke to Caroline Knox and
she and it was really sad today to see
what was happening to Mary Black he was
a trans Ally and when anybody stands up
for us when any person puts their head
above the parapet the little Twitter
Twitter trolls come out and they just
try and cut them down and it's really
sad Frida unfortunately we run out of
time but we did bring you on so we could
hear hear from your point of view I
think that pink chair has done something
to you you're a pussycat now
it was great to speak to you thanks so
much Luke hi uncensored next tonight the
latest on the mysterious mushroom deaths
investigation we bought you that last
night we headed back down under next
foreign
[Music]
Trump yeah look at him fail not working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks do you believe you can
win this wall this is making me cry
again I'm trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
standard he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appears to
be an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty KTM that would make her a better
princess of wealth because you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know I know you're probably going
to vote me off
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to unstances where I'm
joined by the Thursday night pack in the
studio lawyer and talk TV contributor
Paula Roan Adrian talk TV International
editor Isabelle oakshots and talk TV
presenter Richard Tice but first let's
cross to Australia shall we to get the
very latest on that deadly mushroom
mystery we bought you yesterday it's
been gripping the world Sky News
Australia host and journalist Jenna
Clark is ready to update us all on the
latest Jenna um just run us through what
has happened in the last 24 hours in
this
well Rosanna if you are a little bit
squeamish you have to be prepared
because this story just keeps getting
even more and more terrifyingly
revolting Beef Wellington was apparently
on the menu of the day of that fateful
lunch which is what Erin Patterson who
Still Remains a suspect but police have
told us that she it still could all be
very very innocent and that's a direct
quote from Victoria Police just this
morning uh because Beef Wellington was
on the menu uh when those three people
did suffer from death cap mushroom
poisoning and have later died Ian
Wilkinson who was one of the Pastors in
the friends involved in that lunch Still
Remains in a critical condition in
hospital the only latest update I have
for you is that Aaron Patterson who we
must reiterate is still uh as completely
innocent there's no allegations being
made but she has gone to Melbourne which
is about a two-hour drive to meet
specifically with her lawyers uh
interesting of course and we're just
showing our viewers that sort of what we
call doorstep footage there when Aaron
was confronted by reporters and of
course he looked very anguished she said
she denied ever being involved in
anything and she obviously missed the
family members that have now passed away
or in-laws we should say uh Jenna thank
you very much for the update and for
getting up blindingly early for us over
there in Australia I'm sure we'll be
doing it again with you the next couple
of days there's a lot of interest in
this story
thanks Rosanna well coming to the pack
now here in the studio and we've got
some interesting Thursday night stories
to dice up between you just in the
commercial break there we're talking
about this first one which we're calling
bad influences um but it's basically
about rioting can we call it that sort
of bad behavior in central London this
was happening yesterday we probably have
some video to show our viewers but
teenagers basically organize on social
media to all uh meet up in various
locations around Oxford Street which is
bang smack in the middle Central London
very touristy District as well you can
see the the right the sort of bad
behavior that Unleashed there was a lot
of police presence because it was
expected basically
um a note went out on Tick Tock to
teenagers that makes me sound so old and
note uh where they were saying to each
other come and meet up outside this
particular sports shop and we're going
to do a mugging and you know the
language used was basically don't come
unless you can run and gave people
advice on what to wear and we were just
talking about our experiences in Oxford
Street recently
um when you go there and I've been quite
shocked recently going
um how sort of how much disarray there
seems to be I mean Paula you went there
on Monday I went there on Monday and I
have to say I was shocked I was shocked
at the um the amount of homeless people
who were there
um I was shocked at the amount of shops
that were boarded up
um I was just shocked at the general
state of the place it looked like it
didn't look like the Oxford Street that
I know
um but I have to say this story actually
isn't about rampaging teenagers this
story is about an unregulated social
media
because what I thought when I saw this
was almost a Time pre-social media was a
2011 summer riots which a lot of us who
lived in London at the time really lived
through which was essentially bored
teenagers with nothing better to do we
was poorer there that this is more about
social media than it is about a culture
Behavior
everybody knew this was going to happen
there were messages going backwards and
forwards I'm on Tick Tock I put up
messages about the law and some of them
get taken down and it takes me days to
say to tick tock this needs to go back
up and this is the reason why here we
have teenagers young people who are
clearly saying come and uh you know
engage in these criminal activities and
Tick Tock allow these messages to
continue I'm confused by that no you're
totally right about that and absolutely
that should not be allowed I mean
Richard you've got experience of your
own posts being taken down not on Tick
Tock but on other platform it was I was
taken down by Tick Tock from apparently
for hate speech and for inciting
violence because I didn't want gender
questioning and social transitioning in
schools and that's what their lawyers
said and they decided to keep the
cancellation and yet as Paula quite
right it says they're quite happy to
promote and allow and advertising the
you know a get-together for shoplifting
and theft but I don't think we should
take away from the fact that there is a
culture that has allowed this to happen
in the first place I mean you've got to
think carefully about what is the
responsibility of us as a society that
we have we are in a position where young
people think this is a way of having a
like a fun night out you know and the
reason is because there is no real fear
of any consequence and the reason for
that is that the government has stopped
putting pressure on the police to
prosecute each and every one of uh cases
of theft
today saying that she wanted each and
every one of the teenagers that was
involved in this I think her wording was
don't go as hunted down or targeted
found basically and yeah she doesn't
want to pull up the the corporate the
corporates in relation to this we we're
not just talking about teenagers who are
you know participating in criminal
activity we're talking about teenagers
who have lost their lives due to their
activities of social media and parents
who fight and fight and fight and fight
and constantly hit brick walls because
the government will not rein in social
media Giants and here is another example
let me blame the child the teenager the
youth who of course is doing something
wrong of course they are I'm not going
to take that away from them but in terms
of responsibility the responsibility
rests with us responsibility rests with
social media Giants who've allowed that
to happen they allowed that to happen I
actually think that's the simplest thing
to tackle you know it's not that
difficult for the government to crack
down on that to issue very very clear
instructions to social media companies
that they cannot allow this what is much
harder to tackle because it is built up
over a long period of time is the
culture that has allowed us to get into
this place look let's move on to another
story Richard I'll come to you on this
NHS waiting lists uh because it is a
real problem now uh topping 7.6 million
people in NHS England waiting to start
treatment at the end of June it's up
from 7.5 million in May a NHS truly
creaking here and and this of course is
one of the prime minister's five key
pledges that he would get the waiting
list down and ever since they're going
up and up and up and he can't just blame
the strikes this is because
fundamentally we've got an NHS that is
that is like many parts of our Public
Services is essentially broken of course
there are elements of great work done on
the front line but the NHS needs
fundamental reform and the government's
just done absolutely nothing I mean
there are aspects of it that are just
quite extraordinarily dysfunctional and
ridiculous just to give an example which
I gave on Mike Graham's show this
morning of a friend of mine who has a
suspicious lump wanted to get that scene
to of course you would uh went private
because it was going to take too long to
get a an examination by a consultant on
the NHS went to one of the best
urologists in this country a consultant
who used to work for both the NHS and
the private sector up until very
recently the consultant says yup you
need to have that thing removed and the
referral letter which the consultant
sent for the GP was not accepted by the
NHS because he's not an NHS consultant
anymore that is ludicrous the patient is
now waiting to get on a waiting list so
don't be deceived by the way by this 7.6
million because there are millions of
people who aren't even on the waiting
list so I mean some say you know
privatization is almost inevitable this
way or some sort of hybrid it's already
happened Rosanna it's already happened
those who can afford go private and it's
as simple as that and many of those who
can't I was just going to say and many
of those who can't afford put it on
their credit cards and get themselves in
debt and and I just want to get some
figures out here so in terms of the
junior doctor strike tomorrow the um the
the BMA tell us that it would cost
approximately a million pounds I sort of
forgive me a billion pounds to pay the
junior doctors what they wanted we have
other departments saying that it would
cost two billion pounds one billion
pounds 2 billion let me just give you
one example of the BBL loans the the
loans that Banks were able to give out
when and during covid how much of those
47 billion pounds do you think the
government are going to see back I don't
want to even though okay we're going to
but I can tell you how much we're going
to write off exactly 17 billion is
estimated to be written off just on
those loans at all
even with the doctors paid whatever they
want it's not going to make a difference
it's got to use the private sector and
let's remember the last person to use
the private sector was Tony Blair and
the waiting list came down and down and
down and that is the sort of thing we've
got to fundamentally reform 80 of people
don't care who treats them they just
want the paint gone they're just exactly
just want the plane going uh thank the
three of you for a very interesting
discussion there across London but also
the NHS as well on census next tonight
with 70 and Builders saying they've
Fallen victim to having their skip
filled with other people's rubbish find
out what happened with our live stream
filmed the central London skit for 24
hours
thank you
foreign
[Music]
coming up on The Talk The Met police
chief Cersei wants to sack hundreds of
officers accused of wrongdoing but the
law won't let him the number of migrants
crossing the channel in small boats has
hit more than a hundred thousand in the
past five years and at hospitals being
criticized for referring to women as
patients of childbearing potential
that's at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to uncentered where we've
decided to cover the latest streaming
sensation but not on Netflix or Amazon
Prime no skip watch TV yeah that's about
hundreds of Brits have been tuning in
online to watch a live streamed video of
a skip
breaking news there this is the skip
this is live footage we're going to
treat it with all the dignity and
reverence that live television news
footage should be treated with you're
watching the skip there waiting to see
if anybody approached it no a bloke is
just eating a fried egg in the cafe
behind it uh this skip is basically a
camera focused on it and it's kind of
bringing up
um people who are sort of indecently
flight of being in it's an internet
phenomenon now is launched this week
after a poll of 250 British Builders
revealed fly tippers use the skips and
it's one of their biggest pet peeves and
of course as all people I think British
people in particularly we like seeing
you know catching people out doing
naughty stuff don't we I'm joined live
by Brad and Sam from The Bold Builders
breakfast show on fixed radio they
launched this Crusade and fly tipping
welcome to the show guys uh yeah it's to
stop fly tipping but did you think it
would get this much traction
uh to be honest we was having a laugh
with we've been on a show to be fair we
just stop at my house and I've had about
20 skips on the job recently doing a
refurb and I reckon two of them was full
up with rubbish that weren't mine so
they cost me about a thousand pounds
let's say in in skips that that I
shouldn't have actually paid for so then
we started bringing it up on the radio
show having a laugh and a joke and in
one of our listeners he rang in and he
said he found a dead pig in one oh
and it was a blue eye looking at you oh
my God
I'm sorry I shouldn't laugh that's
terrible the pig but oh my God yeah yeah
this is extraordinary stuff um look
let's show our viewers some of the
people you've caught on your live stream
uh here
um this is you know captured people's
imagination look let's oh oh I mean
we've all been a little guilty maybe of
a prep coffee cup or something at some
point
[Laughter]
it's serious stuff isn't it let's give
you some stats at least 70 percent of
Builders claim to fall and victim to
having their skit filled with other
people's rubbish
um yeah you've said it it cost you
almost a thousand quid at one point do
you hope that this campaign will stop
people make people think
of awareness to the situation the other
thing we could do is I adore moon for
skips we were thinking about that having
a security guard
love this very good we just want to
highlight our viewers to another
campaign you've got going which is uh
the best color cup of tea this again on
your radio show uh yeah let's ask the
panel here uh if you can see that uh
where you fit on the Spectrum I'm
certainly more in the 2C columns snap 2C
yeah my eyesight is good enough for this
second row far right second right
that's quite milky ties that's quite
milky yeah is mine actually yeah
first you see you can't do that
absolutely milk in second I think you'll
unite the nation on that um uh tell us
how you like to have your tea lads
I like my cup of tea I like a Yorkshire
Tea Bag two sweeteners milk goes in
afterwards give it a little broom I
don't know 10 seconds or so and I do me
lovely PG tip milk in First Two Sugars
he's a wrong one
[Laughter]
in on a building side you reckon on
every night it's like 15 cups oh my God
15. no time to do any work you've been
in the Lou all day
before you go we want to ask you about
one vaguely serious story in the news
the moment which is about this crooked
Pub
um this is a pub of course in England it
was supposedly one of Britain's wonkiest
buildings and it was bought by
um somebody and then we won't get into
the logistics of this legal battle but
basically it's burnt down and people are
wondering whether it should be rebuilt
as crooked if you guys got the job to
come and rebuild it would you take it on
and would you build it crooked yeah I
think so I think I've run every weekend
Friday Saturday night if we turn on
Monday morning it'll probably look like
that'll be fair
you're fired you're not hired
great value
Builders of fixed radio thank you so
much uh we'll bring our viewers back to
the live foot viewing of the skip we
really hope that we're going to catch
somebody live here on Piers Morgan
uncensored dropping their rubbish in but
I just want to come back to the pack and
ask you do you think you've been guilty
of this don't worry we won't tell the
authorities
I am a practice embarrister as you know
so I'm gonna plead the fifth on this one
okay
I definitely haven't and I love the way
the builders all said it costs them a
thousand pounds because in reality
mostly it costs the client a thousand
pounds twelve hundred pounds whoever is
actually quite exactly yeah whoever's
hired the builders has to pay for the
skip so I don't know I've probably been
a victim of it that's what I feel I I
may have accidentally let slip as I walk
past with my pretty much a cup and just
happened to slip it by mistake into this
because we have jobs are witness an
honest politician
that's the difference between me and the
rest of them hey goodness man
[Laughter]
that is it from me and all of us here in
the studio whatever you're up to tonight
make sure it's uncensored
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail start working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again I'm trying
to force you out yes I feel betrayed
keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through
some way is an excuse
for at what
it is to be an abuse of power when they
first got together there were press
stories weighty Katie that would make
her a better princess of wealth because
you're not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has